inflation is coming down and yet you
still want a significant pay rise how
are we justifying that
I think after four years without pay
rise okay I think we can justify it I
think as you know I spoke to you before
unlike other key workers rail workers
did their jobs during the pandemic and
of course living crisis is everyone and
what we've seen to have is a government
that wants to take all our terms and
conditions
um for a 20 pay cut that's going to
happen
you're saying four percent isn't enough
how much is enough
well when we get a deal that's
acceptable uh we'll let you know at this
moment of time we've been back at the
talks up and see at Christmas and
experienced overseas we sat there for
months uh scoped out our red lines and
then they put all our red lines into the
ultimately they can fail this is a
government and a group of people that do
not want a resolution to this right
when was the last time you held talks
with the government
well I haven't seen anyone from the
government since January the 6th and why
do you think that is
not interested they don't care they
don't want a resolution to this dispute
what do you want to say to the transport
secretary this morning then
transfer secretary to take the shackles
off the people that we're dealing with
and allow us to get a resolution to this
so we can get back to doing our day
trips
how long could these strikes continue
for me
well
for retirement three years
um you were saying that half ingest I'm
guessing
oh yeah look we want a resolution
tomorrow evening get one nobody wants to
be losing money nobody wants to be on
strike we want to get our timetables
back move on rail at the center of Green
Revolution we'll be talking about things
I've been talking about the last 12
years not why I've had to talk about the
last 14 months
what do you have to say to people who
won't be able to get to work today or um
perhaps to The Cup final at the weekend
or the derby
one people to get about and do their
business we want Leisure traffic to grow
we want the railways to come back but we
are not at all here he said
government-led strikes I don't have a
problem with Scotland I don't have a
problem in Wales we don't have a problem
with Frey we don't have a problem with
Open Access we don't have a problem on
the tube or the overground we've got a
problem with Westminster who will not
allow a deal to be struggled
you're saying four percent isn't enough
though uh but you won't tell me what is
oh nobody's come to the table with
something that's viable and this isn't
four percent straight and bearing in
mind inflation it's a two-year deal so
the first year was inflation was 13.8 so
that's a 10 fake huh and last year we
reached a higher 13.4 and it's still
north of ten percent so for a 20 pickup
people will take on that terms that is
the Bible
yeah and as you say though the
government has left you to it they're no
longer interested in uh having
conversations with you as far as your
concerned so we've reached a bit of a
stalemate haven't we
believe
at any time to find a way out of this we
want a resolution sooner rather than
later we do not want to beat it the 20
or 30 people standing behind me on the
picket line do not want to be here today
I'd much rather be at work they would
not like they do not want to be losing
money